merci merci beaucoup de votre invitation
les contraintes juridiques
je vais essayer d'aller à l'essentiel il
me semble que la principale contrainte
juridique aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
appelle en droit le principe de la
hiérarchie des normes qui se traduit
concrètement par le fait que tout accord
international ou bilatéral négocié par
la france en matière d'immigration a une
force supérieure à la loi alors je suis
pas en train de dire que les lois qu'on
discute au parlement n'ont pas beaucoup
d'importance il ya dans cette salle
beaucoup de parlementaires
je ne m'aventurerai pas sur ce terrain
je suis simplement en train de dire
qu'au fil des années la france a tissé
soit avec des pays du maghreb et
d'afrique soit avec d'autres pays
européens
un réseau d'accords qui est aujourd'hui
déterminant pour la conduite et demain
pour la réorientation de notre politique
en matière migratoire et je vais prendre
trois exemples le premier exemple que je
vais prendre
il n'est pas du tout d'actualité je m'en
excuse auprès de vous c'est l'exemple de
l'algérie la france est liée à l'algérie
par des accords en matière migratoire
qui ont été négociées au lendemain de la
guerre d'algérie en 1962 et 1963 qui ont
été un peu toiletter depuis et qui sont
aujourd'hui en matière migratoire
complètement décalé par rapport à la
législation française
pour faire court à partir de 1986 les
gouvernements de la droite française et
à partir de 1986 était sous l'impulsion
de charles pasqua ont essayé de rénover
la législation française dans le sens
d'une meilleure maîtrise des flux
migratoires
et nous avons adopté toute une série de
dispositions qui s'appliquent aux
étrangers qui ne sont pas régis par des
accords bilatéraux
eh bien ces dispositions celle que
charles pasqua a fait voter en 86 88
celle que nicolas sarkozy et brice
hortefeux ont fait adopter pour faire
court entre 2005 et 2010 ces
dispositions de droit commun elle ne
s'applique pas aujourd'hui aux
ressortissants algériens et je rappelle
que les algériens sont la première
nationalité pour l'admission au séjour
en france on nous parle aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'autres nationalités mais
quand on fait le compte
sur les 200 mille étrangers qui
obtiennent grosso modo chaque année un
titre de séjour en france
la nationalité qui arrive en tête c'est
ce sont les algériens
donc nous ne pourrons pas retrouver la
maîtrise de nos flux migratoires si nous
ne sommes pas capables de renégocier
notre accord avec l'algérie je vais
prendre un exemple très concret tout le
monde comprendra il y avait autrefois
dans la législation française sur
l'immigration une disposition qui était
une prime à la clandestinité
c'est à dire qu'un étranger qui avait
réussi à se maintenir sur le territoire
français dix ans en situation
irrégulière
la loi prévoyait qu on lui donnait un
titre de séjour
cette disposition elle a été supprimée
dans la loi de 2005 si je ne me trompe
eh bien elle figure toujours dans
l'accord qui lie la france à l'algérie
à ma connaissance donc voilà un premier
exemple très concret de normes
juridiques qui s'imposent à nous et
qu'il faudra renégocier et je dis tout
de suite que c'est pas simple de
renégocier un accord international
mais je dis tout de suite aussi que
c'est possible et que nous l'avons fait
avec un pays qui est beaucoup plus petit
que l'algérie et la tunisie nous avons
renégocié en 2008 notre accord
migratoire avec la tunisie et nous avons
par exemple supprimer la clause dont je
viens de parler
deuxième sujet les quotas
les quotas il ya beaucoup de pays dans
le monde qui maîtrisent l'immigration en
définissant chaque année des quotas et
les exemples les plus connus c'est
l'exemple du canada est l'exemple de
l'australie est donc une bonne partie de
l'opinion publique française se pose la
question mais comment se fait-il que
nous n'adoptons pas une politique de
quotas et je crois pouvoir dire eric
woerth rappelait au début de cette
réunion que même si nous avons parfois
des nuances entre nous nous faisons
partie de la même famille politique je
crois pouvoir dire que nous sommes tous
d'accord pour dire qu'il faudrait aller
vers une politique de quotas simplement
sur la route de cette politique de
quotas il ya un obstacle qui résulte
d'une norme juridique international qui
est la convention européenne des droits
de l'homme et notamment son article 8
qui proclame le droit au respect de la
vie privée et familiale ce qui pose
problème c'est pas l'article 8 ans soit
encore que naturellement il vous a pas
échappé que ni le canada ni l'australie
ne sont signataires de la convention
européenne des droits mais ce qui pose
problème c'est pas l'article 8 en soit
c'est l'interprétation qu'en fait la
jurisprudence qu'en font les tribunaux
français à la fois tribunaux
administratifs et tribunaux judiciaires
et qu'en fait la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme est donc une question
qui était jusqu alors absolument tabou
et qui est en train d'émerger dans le
débat sur l'immigration
c est ce qu il est possible de revoir la
jurisprudence de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme est ce qu'il est
possible de réviser éventuellement la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme est ce qu'il est possible et la
proposition n'a été faite d'ores et déjà
par plusieurs des responsables de l'ump
je crois que guillaume larrivé guillaume
larrivé et pierre lellouche
au nombre des colas sarkozy se sont
aventurés sur ce terrain je crois savoir
également que françois fillon a dit des
choses sur le sujet une question qui
était autrefois absolument tabou et
qu'il n'est plus aujourd'hui c'est est
ce qu'il faut pas envisager sérieux
heureusement de dénoncer la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme ensuite
de ré adhérer à cette convention mais en
formulant des réserves comme l'ont fait
un certain nombre de pays et je pense
notamment à la grande bretagne de
manière à ce que nous puissions faire
prévaloir une interprétation de
l'article 8 qui soit compatible avec
notre volonté de maîtriser l'immigration
familiale parce que si nous ne résolvons
pas cette contrainte juridique
je suis désolé de le dire on se
maintiendra sur le terrain des discours
et pas sur le terrain d'un vrai
changement de la politique migratoire
enfin je vais aborder parce que j'ai pas
beaucoup de temps j'aborde un troisième
et dernier sujet et qui lui est
totalement dans l'actualité c'est
schengen moi j'ai fais partie je devrais
pas dire ça j'ai fait partie des équipes
qui ont négocié l'accord ce qu'on
appelle l'application de l'accord de
schengen l'accord de schengen c'est 2006
1985 et l'accord d'application qui est
l'accord concrets qui nous crée des
obligations précises c'est 1989 et à
l'époque la france avait parfaitement vu
la question des ressortissants non
européens
il y avait une demande très forte des
européens pour dire on est en train de
construire un espace sans frontières et
on veut pouvoir circuler librement à
l'intérieur de cet espace
mais cette demande elle concerner les
ressortissants de l'union européenne les
ressortissants des pays qui avaient
adhéré à la convention de schengen elle
concernait pas nécessairement les
ressortissants des pays tiers et ce qui
a prévalu en 1989 ce qui a prévalu après
une timide résistance du gouvernement
français de l'époque qui est assez vite
lâché ce qui a prévalu c'est une
conception que je qualifierais à la fois
d'intégristes et d'angélique
de la libre circulation à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne
on est tous d'accord je le rappelle pour
dire que quand canton constitue un
espace commun que ce soit à schengen où
que ce soit l'union européenne on est
tous d'accord pour dire qu'il faut
contrôler avec beaucoup de sévérité la
frontière extérieure
là-dessus il n'y a pas de débat le débat
c'est qu'est ce qui se passe aux
frontières intérieures terreau
frontières par exemple entre la france
et l'allemagne entre la france et
l'italie entre la hongrie et l'autriche
et c'est le débat il est là est la
question c'est est ce qu'on fait
bénéficier à ses frontières intérieures
est-ce qu'on fait bénéficier les
ressortissants des pays qui
n'appartiennent pas à l'union européenne
du même droit de libre circulation que
les ressortissants de l'union européenne
en 1989 quand on a construit schengen on
a répondu oui à cette question on a dit
on peut pas distinguer entre un
ressortissant européen et un
ressortissants non européens
il y avait des arguments dans ce sens 1
si vous pour dire les choses pour
appeler les choses par leur nom
c'est pas toujours facile de distinguer
je veux prendre par exemple un pays qui
n'appartient pas aujourd'hui à schengen
la serbie n'appartient pas à schengen
quand un ressortissant serbe se présente
à une frontière intérieure à l'intérieur
de l'union européenne
voilà on devine pas que il apparaît
qu'il n'appartient pas à un pays de
l'union européenne c'est la raison pour
laquelle à l'époque on a fait prévaloir
cette conception intégrée de la libre
circulation
je dis pas nécessairement qu'il faut la
remettre en cause
mais je constate qu'aujourd'hui la
question est posée et que c'est nouveau
c'est nouveau parce que quand l'union
européenne s'est élargie elle s'est
élargie aux anciens pays d'europe
centrale
ces pays il avait vécu derrière le
rideau de fer et pour eux la libre
circulation c'était une demande absolue
pour eux adhérer à l'europe
c'était bénéficier de la libre
circulation vous pensez il avait vécu
pendant des années dans des pays où pour
sortir il fallait demander une
autorisation
donc pour eux adhérer à l'ue
opn c'était adhérer un espace de libre
circulation ce qui est en train de se
passer depuis quelques jours
depuis quelques jours c'est qu'on voit
que ces pays d'europe centrale qui
étaient les gardiens les plus fervents
du dogme de la libre circulation absolue
à l'intérieur de l'union européenne
ils sont en train de se poser des
questions alors je conclus il nous
faudra en 2010 est d'excellent
parlementaire pour travailler sur les
lois françaises et notamment par exemple
revoir la loi sur l'asile qui vient
d'être votée qui est radicalement
insuffisante mais il nous faudra aussi
des équipes de négociateurs pour aller
porter la voix de la france dans les
discussions sur la révision de toutes
les normes internationales qui s'impose
à nous et que je viens d'évoquer
et j'aurai terminé sur une note qui
n'est pas très optimiste et je m'en
excuse
la france n'aura pas nécessairement au
départ beaucoup d'alliés dans ce combat
parce qu'elle n'est pas dans la même
situation que la plupart des autres pays
de l'union européenne moi je suis pas du
tout contre l'idée de construire une
politique commune d'immigration et
d'asile en europe il faut le faire il
nous faut absolument un socle commun
dans ce domaine et il nous fait encore
largement défaut mais il faudra aussi
prendre en compte la situation
particulière de la france
la france elle a une démographie qui
n'est pas du tout celle de l'allemagne
on vient de le voir et qui grosso modo
n'est pas non plus celle de la plupart
des pays européens
michèle tribalat nous a parlé du poids
accumulé de l'immigration sur la réalité
sociologique de la société française
mais il ya aussi une réalité
d'aujourd'hui c'est que la france a
grosso modo une fécondité qui lui permet
de renouveler chaque année sa population
nous avons une population active qui ne
diminuent pas à la différence de
beaucoup d'autres pays européens
il nous faudra donc à partir de 2017
engagé la révision d'un certain nombre
d'accords internationaux
moi quand j'entends nicolas sarkozy dire
qu'il faudra refonder schengen c'est ce
que je comprends ça veut pas dire m je
t'ai schengen aux orties c'est ce qui
fait la différence
pascal perrineau de souligner tout à
l'heure entre nos convictions et celles
du front national
mais il faudra une révision une révision
de beaucoup des accords internationaux
auxquels la france est partie et cette
révision elle devra tenir compte des
intérêts particuliers de la france